I defend from the sky and land on things
really hard and I go at everything with
that amount of fury every damn person
who said I wouldn't be anything I'm
crushing them every day what are you
doing tomorrow 8 o'clock on stage we're
doing the night after I'll be on stage
we're about two months from now I'll be
still on that same tour he's an American
musician actor writer and comedian he
fronted the hardcore California punk
band Black Flag he hosts a weekly radio
show and is a regular columnist for LA
Weekly
he's Henry Rollins and here's my take on
his top ten roots of success rule number
six is my personal favorite and I'd love
to know which one you guys like the back
and as always guys as you're watching
the videos if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well
also as viewer writing something down
it's much more likely to stick in your
head enjoy
[Music]
you want to set an interview that your
life is paranoia and fear and you're
just trying to not get hit yeah that's
still true yeah
anger and fear fear of failure drives me
paranoia of things going wrong around me
drives me I'm driven by a lot of like
really kind of ugly anger and so I have
a lot of that in me and it comes from a
father who is terrifying
and teachers who yelled at me told me
I'd never be anything and so I descend
from the sky and land on things really
hard and I go at everything with that
amount of fury and I'm not saying I'm
going to hit anybody and I'm not mad at
you I'm quite happy to be an answer any
question to the best of my ability when
I go at everything like you think I
can't hey you want to try acting y'all
try acting can you ask No so let's go I
say something that I can you can act
thank you Ferris for losers I'd rather
win intend to be incredibly modest in
terms of describing your talents and you
you always seem to belittle your your
abilities to a certain extent when
clearly there there's a reason why this
everything you do has been working out I
was reading about how you said that to
certain extent that comes from your your
punk rock roots yep there's no other
choice
in those days there's no idea of this
makes money
there's no idea like this is my future
it was like a week at a time they have
five shows we're going to get to Sunday
and even those days are like fraught
with turbulence and so I never really
saw a future none of us did and some of
us you know didn't make it some of them
are dead and some of them are just kind
of trying to recreate their past and so
I realized that I have to be very
hard-working
because I don't have kind of the ease of
talent and I come from that I think it's
a lot of ways that served me very well
in that I am is kind of hardworking as
I've ever been completely unconfident
and I have none I don't I don't want any
because I think you turn your back on
the thing and that's when you get gored
is when you think I got this
I never think I got this I think oh man
don't screw this up and I go with
everything like including you and I
sitting here right now I'm trying to be
fully engaged and that intensity I think
has served me quite well but it comes
from punk rock absolutely last boss I
ever had was my boss at haagen-dazs my
my ice cream shop and to this day he
still comes to my shows and whenever I
see Steve who got me my first apartment
Julio's living in my car he believed in
me whenever I see him I get all weepy
III also it's good to see you sir Henri
you can call me Steve I can't do that
sir because because he trusted me with
his money and and I said let me run your
store I know how to do this I can do
this he's like well if you screw up
you're out of guy said I won't screw up
when I end up being I ran a store and so
it would but it was anger that said I'll
be here all damn week I'll get this
whole thing right I fired a staff and we
hired a bunch of people can really work
and it was out of anger like I'll be
back in four hours to run this $3 and 75
cent an hour job into the ground and
then I joined Black Flag and I thought I
was a hardworking person then you meet
the guys in Black Flag who are so driven
you see Greg Ginn work 23 hour days like
Greg you're still on the phone I know
Greg when did you eat I don't know Greg
when the last time you showered on do we
have a shower like the guy was we were
not going to be stopped and I kind of go
at that intensity
what kind of anything I do a you're very
calm good-looking young man look at me
I'm a spaz sitting next to you like I'm
doing an interview with you focus I'm
sweating man and so
but I like it going to the airport like
ten miles out and so it's but it's anger
that has informed kind of my life and
unflatteringly a sense of vengeance
every damn person who said I wouldn't be
anything I'm crushing them every day
everybody I had to endure in any band I
was in everyday into a powder yeah thank
you and I wish them no ill I just wish
to shine brighter and if it burns my
body to a crisp I'm happy to go right
now I just do my work for me I've always
been very utilitarian on all of this
stuff and that's what coming from punk
rock gave to me well I don't feel like
I'm anybody and someone wants me to sign
something I'm like sure I don't exactly
understand why but I'll do it for you I
don't think I'm anything maybe it's also
not just because of the punk rock
mentality is also because you were
scooping ice cream not so long ago and
maybe there's an element of insecurity
in you that unless you keep working and
keep keep striving you could end up back
there oh I kind of figured that's
eventual I keep moving forward boldly
because I have nothing to lose I'm
nobody from nowhere you should really
understand that I am from the minimum
wage working world a hundred years ago
but I I don't ever have it in my head
that that's any less any more than one
tour away of coming back and so I just
read I like to work it's not about money
or fame or anything is about activity
and challenge I was a very headstrong
young person and by nineteen eighty
three or four had started my own
publishing company to publish my own
books realizing that no one else will
publish me and I was right about that
and so my first book I saved my food
money from Black Flag little here little
there and I saved enough to make a fold
and staple book I couldn't type so I
hand write out the things and I made a
dummy and I could offset print fold and
staple and I sold them for two dollars
mainly gave them away but I sold enough
and they blew out 500 just
and then I took that money to make
another print run of that and from that
money I made my first paper back and 33
years later that's a fully staffed
company with books in translation and
hardcover editions and the whole in on
the whole nine yards but it started with
I'm going to do my thing I'll be city
lights jr. without the talent and that's
I did that at the same time I was doing
my first spoken word gigs and why did I
have the gumption and the audacity to
start my own book company because I come
from punk rock I come from watching Ian
MacKaye invent discord records on his
mom's kitchen table I come from folding
and gluing picture sleeves together
black flag had their own label of course
you do it yourself you want to make a
book sit down and write it then go to
the printing place where as a printer
getting a phone book and find a printer
we make records make some books it was
you just do it if you even think about
just do it I'm sure that writing is this
awful but I did it and without even
hesitation I'm making my own book
companies stop me I dare you I've never
thought about it twice just because DIY
man like let your voice be heard
our last straight job I had was 1981
head manager of a haagen-dazs in
Georgetown in Washington DC on Wisconsin
Avenue at the intersection of Wisconsin
and oh sweet making 375 and our four
dollars an hour or something like that
working 40 to 60 hours a week I had a
small apartment which I shared with an
old pal of mine
I had a small record collection an
ailing VW automobile and a little tiny
life with my minimum wage job which I
were I liked and I looked at my life and
realized this is probably about as good
as it's going to get for me I might quit
this place and go work at my friends
record store because I like to being
around records that I could probably run
his store very well knowing what I knew
about retail at that point and then I
got a very lucky break because at that
same time I was very frustrated
I said well
this is going to be a very tough life it
can be a life of a lot of standing on my
feet a lot of work taking it from other
people and having very little to show
for it by Friday you know Friday evening
and then Black Flag the famous band
whose friends of mine they played in New
York I was in Washington I took a ride
up to go see him because they weren't
coming down to my town I jumped on stage
and sang with him at night a song
because I had to go back down to DC and
go work like some awful shift they
called me a few days later at the ice
cream store and said you know we're
looking for a singer because the rhythm
guitar player wants to I'm sorry the
vocalist wants to move down to rhythm
guitar tell it told the story before and
we're holding auditions you want to
crack at this because we tell you
onstage you tonight you're pretty wild I
looked at the ice cream scoop in my hand
my chocolate bespattered apron and my
future in the world of minimum-wage work
or I couldn't go up to New York and
audition for this crazy band who was my
favorite what's the worst that's going
to happen to me I miss a day of work
whoo there goes 21 bucks and I get
humiliated in front of my favorite band
and humiliation and young people kind of
go together I was used to it and so I I
took a train up there I walk into this
practice place in the East Village I'm
standing there with the band with a
microphone in my hand they said pick the
tune and I sang every song they had you
know improvising most of it two times
through we did the set they said okay
you have a seat we're going to have a
band meeting
whatever that means and they came back
like 10 minutes later okay you're in I
said what do you mean they say you're
the singer in Black Flag I said it's a
little idea they go you quit your job
you pack your gear you meet us on the
road here's this year's a tour itinerary
here's the lyrics we'll see you soon
so fairly numb I went back down to
Washington with this passel of lyrics in
my hand went to my boss and said I'm not
exactly quitting but here's this thing
that happened and he said it's your shot
I said yeah he said take it I feel a
genuine need to communicate with an
audience
and it might just be the attention I
didn't get as a kid I can't come from
anything good but what I try and do is
bring the best information I can to the
stage and and broadcast it so I'm it's
reportage from distant points from a
fairly unique standpoint and so
basically I'm not keeping it all to
myself but I earnestly tried to us not
about entertainment it's about
communication warning broadcasting
admitting and trying to leave something
of myself with these with the audience
not just not mere entertainment it's not
just making people laugh or not it's
it's got to hurt me it's got to leave
lines in my face I don't like any
artistic endeavor that doesn't extol a
price on the one doing it so I'm not
looking to get through these things okay
these things are actually very difficult
and very hard on my psyche which makes
me think I'm doing the right thing
guys like me have to do everything three
times before we get it right
thankfully I know that so I know that I
have to get up early and try it five
times because the eight-year-old will be
able to get past it into time so I have
to be on my feet longer but at least I
know it and so I just go at stuff and it
serves me very well and that my resume
is pretty varied and I have a pretty
interesting life y'all get to do
different stuff and have a bit of access
because I just said y'all try that I
mean why would I hold back the repeating
factors of my life have been application
discipline focus repetition you know a
gig a gig again what are you doing
tomorrow 8 o'clock on stage we're doing
the night after I'll be on stage we're
about 2 months from now I'll be still on
that same tour because I manage myself I
know where I'm going I might finish it I
might not survive it but I'm the one
book in it hastin what I'm thinking
about the future or the past the future
why that because I wanted because this
past
hold all of your mistakes and
humiliations the future holds whatever
you can make it and so the past has
already been determined and also
although your victories and all your
accomplishments but all the bad stuff is
there too so why dwell learn from it and
move on don't ignore it and don't say it
didn't happen don't deny it
but don't you don't have to dwell in it
and be miserable that happens enough to
us adults already you see someone from
your patrick ah I still hurt but the
futures ready for you to not make those
mistakes and to make it great now that I
have less future than I do past I seek
to make them well over the 50-yard line
of mortality 55 you know there's no way
I'm getting 110 out of this all right
you never know the same for any
energetic I was that well it might just
burn me out but knowing I have less in
front of me than behind me why not be
cool that don't mean guys seem like a
look you got some time left rock out
like like make it amazing where the pass
has been done
is on the fly
watch
and I
Bar
dare you lie
come on
ah
[Applause]
[Applause]
ah
always
what
he's gonna wash away
[Applause]
please
please
are you
I'm telling you
Oh
Thompson single charge
my my
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Kurt asked me to
so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it
down the comments below and I'll see
what I can do
I'd also love to know what is Henry said
that had the biggest impact on you and
why what message did you take for him
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life for your business somehow
leave it down the comments and I'm going
to join in the discussion finally we
want to give a quick shout out to run by
young Ronda thank you so much for all
your support of my book your one word I
really really really really appreciate
it
[Music]
[Music]
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
I stand with dinosaur jr. last December
because they asked me I did a song don't
which only has why why don't you like me
so even I could get the lyric but I did
it because Jay asked me and I I don't
want to disappoint those guys and I
remember afterwards they all came up
you're like that was really intense and
like this what other way do you do it
especially without gods with dinosaur
thought it was full with Jay and be on
stage with Jay was which is all of them
but that that much guitar volume I that
was something else
I'm a fan big fan of that band but I'm
yeah all of that is still there but if
you're not but if what you're pushing
forward isn't all the way real then if
it's 98% real then the 2% that you're
lying to the crowd shame on you I can't
do that
this is how we'll ground for me and so
if it's not 100% I sadly have to walk
away the reason I do what I do the
reasons why I get to do what I do all
come from 1970 something into 1981 high
school to me leaving punk rock
literature poetry realizing the power of
putting the pen to the paper and
expressing yourself that if you can
write you can write and let's let's
break that sentence down for a minute if
you can form a sentence you can form a
sentence and doesn't matter who you are
it doesn't matter if you're the high
school quarterback going to be with a
pretty girl at the prom or if you're the
loser
which you're not and the person who
doesn't get picked to be on the
basketball team at gym you can write and
you can have as much authority over your
own writing as Flannery O'Connor Ernest
Hemingway or anyone you can imagine you
can have your own and you will find in
your life at some of the only real true
freedom you'll ever get is your
imagination your thoughts and what you
can put on the paper and the good news
is you never ever ever have to show it
to anyone it can be like a meditation
that you could write to yourself you
these angry as you want you can make up
anything you want
you are never freer than when you're
putting it down and I always say pen and
paper because I have an analogue
relationship with writing but if you
want to key it in you can do that too
and you can be a 53 year old man like me
and still do a journal entry every day
as I do because it is part of my ways to
check in with myself like hey Henry how
you doing well I'm pretty sad today
because of this and I'm very angry about
this there's a lot of writing I do
volumes of it that no one sees I never
publish it I just need to check in with
myself through the hand to ink to the
paper and anyone can do that
and you never have to show it to anyone
not your significant other not your
brothers or sisters or parents or
teachers it can be exclusively yours